I have for you today some of the most
disgusting allegations that we have
heard made by Donald Trump and his
family against Democrats Donald Trump
jr. was interviewed on Fox News from the
site of CPAC the Conservative Political
Action Conference over the weekend he
was asked what he thinks of the response
to kovat 19 from Democrats now
understand that this framing in and of
itself is laughable because Donald Trump
is President of the United States Donald
Trump disbanded the pandemic response
team Donald Trump got funding cut to the
CDC and Donald Trump has attacked actual
medical experts for giving their
fact-based view about kovat 19 so why
does it matter what Don junior thinks
about the response from Democrats it's
Donald Trump who's in charge here but ok
Fox decides to ask Don jr. about the
response from Democrats to kovat 19 and
Don junior says Democrats seemingly want
hundreds of millions of people to die in
order to prove a political point and to
have material with which they can attack
the President of the United States take
a look at the video are you surprised
the way they've been handling the
coronavirus situation meaning Democrats
not at all I mean we've seen like you
said we've seen this play out for four
years anything that they can use to try
to hurt Trump they will anything he does
in a positive sense like you heard from
the reporter that was just suspended
from ABC they will not give him credit
for the PlayBook is old at this point
but for them to try to take a pandemic
and seemingly hope that it comes here
and kills millions of people so that
they could end Donald Trump's streak of
winning is a new level of sickness you
know I don't know if this is coronavirus
or Trump derangement syndrome but these
people are infected badly to run that in
the New York Times this isn't Vox this
isn't one of these you know crazy
left-wing journal this is the New York
Times writing this with seriousness it's
truly sick you know Don jr. is
rhetorically skilled he's a quick
thinker he's a fast debater he
not right on the facts of course but
he's eloquent and articulate he happens
to be playing for the wrong team and
it's really a disappointment that
someone with juniors rhetorical skills
on their side is arguing for absolutely
horrible things and is not on the side
of logic and reason because Don Jr is
more than capable of being just as
effective for the left as he is for
Trump the Trump family was lifelong
Democrats until Trump decided he was
going to be a Republican and Don jr.
with the facts on his side on our side
could actually be a really effective
sort of advocate for good policy instead
he is using his rhetorical skills to
spread some of the most disgusting types
of allegations out there which are
regularly used by the right which is to
accuse the left of wanting the country
to fail in order to score political
points and defeat Donald Trump we've
seen this with the stock market people
saying the left wants a stock market
crash the left wants unemployment to go
up just so they can blame it on Trump
I'm often accused of taking joy and
gleefully reporting to you stock market
downturns know this could not be further
from the truth as many of you know I
have been invested in mutual funds for
more than 15 years at this point when I
lose ten percent in four days even if
you say well David you're only saying it
out of self-interest whatever the reason
I do not want the stock market to fall I
do not want the economy to fail I don't
know any serious people on the Left who
do and then even more disgusting than
saying the left wants the economy to
fail is the left wants people to die
nevermind hundreds of millions of people
in a pandemic as a result of poor
preparedness by the United States headed
by Donald Trump merely so that we can
say we've got a vote Trump out now Fox
News contributes to the propaganda Fox
could say hey Don Jr if Democrats want
millions of people to die just to hurt
your dad why are Democrats asking for
more money for virus response than Trump
is willing to give or ask for so we need
to take control of this we can't allow
them to spin it
as the left is overstating the risk from
the virus merely to hurt Trump because
it's as disgusting as it is untrue and
unfortunately starting to get oxygen
yesterday on the sunday shows Mike Pence
refused to deny that Democrats want
people to die and then of course there
are people going even further suggesting
that the virus is either you know a bio
weapon something created in a lab and
really getting getting out there with
dangerous disinformation we're actually
seeing the virus crisis expose all of
Donald Trump's weaknesses at the same
time Jud Legum posted out posted on
Twitter that we are seeing through the
virus response Trump's incompetence
Trump's rejection of scientific facts
Trump's distrust of expertise Trump not
being interested in thinking long-term
Trump embracing conspiracy theories
Trump's paranoia and inability to learn
from his mistakes it's everything in the
story at once and Donald Trump is doing
almost everything wrong while his
propagandists including his own kid are
spreading disgusting baseless
conspiracies such as Dems want millions
of people to die in order to hurt Donald
Trump there was a time when politics was
very partisan and ugly but when it came
to life and death issues like a pandemic
you didn't see this garbage one party
being accused by another of wanting
millions of people to die in order to
score political points times have
changed and that is unfortunately where
we are today